i tried to take a suit once but it's a
little bit difficult to walk out of the
set in a spider-man suit just because
they play heroes on screen doesn't mean
they aren't just a bit morally
compromised i said i didn't do anything
darling actors love keeping a memento
from their time on set but often this
means swiping it when nobody's looking
let's find out what these marvel stars
could get their hands on
number one on top of stealing zendaya's
heart he brought home peter parker's
wardrobe tom holland managed to steal
like all of the graphic tees peter
parker wore throughout the series and he
managed to get his hands on the
sweatshirts he wore in the first movie
too expect to hear about his escapades a
lot in this video he's infamous for
being terrible at keeping secrets it
makes us wonder how much stuff the other
stars have taken but would never ever
admit to
could you get in trouble for it i mean i
haven't so far number two renner is
secretly the most devious of us all
would you be surprised if we told you
jeremy renner is one of the few actors
who hasn't stolen any props from set i
never took anything because they asked
us not to but he did just recently
borrow the hawkeye suit two plus up
volunteering at his daughter's school
and nobody's asked him to return it yet
so
it might be on permanent loan
number three what does hemsworth need so
many hammers for while runner being the
goody two shoes he is couldn't help but
call out his fellow castmate chris
hemsworth for stealing one of thor's
hammers going so far as to call him a
dirtbag what a dirtbag but chris
hemsworth has stolen a bunch of hammers
how many hammers do you have uh about
five 500
and one of his many mjolnirs is covered
in dense thanks to his we child trying
to lift it
hey we thought only thor could do that
what we want to know is how he's able to
walk out with one it isn't like you can
just hide it in your shirt and according
to evans he also got to keep the full
thor suit
i never asked for the full suit
hemsworth got the full suit
i want the full suit
number four robert downey jr stole our
hearts with this one he wins for best
gift giver that's for sure did you know
he was in possession of the original
iron man helmet and we didn't know for
the longest time when rdj was making
doctor doolittle in london he invited
tom holland and his brother patty to a
screening of black panther at his home
tom remembers patty running into the
room holding it the original helmet
that's a really special one for me
because i was lucky enough to join the
mcu but i joined it very late no tom
isn't crying in this clip he's just
eaten a hot wing
number five the god of mischief walks a
straight line tom hiddleston didn't care
to steal anything he'd have to leave on
a shelf no he was gifted something much
more practical for his birthday a black
and gray scarf from the first thor movie
wow that's what i got that's what i got
there you go
it is a very nice scarf we must say but
we did expect the god of mischief to
have a stash of stolen props in his home
come on
what did you expect number six simulu
loved his shoes so much he ran away with
them keeping on track with marvel actors
stealing practical clothing chongqi star
simulu nabbed a pair of movie worn
jordans on his last day of filming the
pair you can see in this scene these
have been artistically scuffed that
isn't even real dirt i split kicked two
bad guys with these shoes number seven
tom holland is totally a klepto but he
isn't great at it
holland tried to sneak a whole spidey
suit off the set once but found it was
just a bit too easy for people to see he
did get away with a couple of smaller
objects though including the web
shooters from a suit and a pair of tony
stark's glasses
my house is littered with props from
films the glasses are now left sitting
on his mantelpiece but we really wish
he'd take them out for a test run they
look fantastic on him holland doesn't
feel too badly about taking them they
always make loads of them because they
break all the time number eight maybe
non-gianni's gift will inspire a
spin-off kumail nanjiani got a hold of
kingo's fake movie posters although he
didn't really steal them they were a
gift and it's kind of a cool prop to
have because at least they don't take up
space to display and we'll fit right in
with the eternals poster we bet he's got
up on his wall emily v gordon
non-gianni's wife said on twitter it may
be the best gift he's ever gotten
i really feel it
number nine when you walk away with the
suit holder but not the suit it's tom
holland again holland took a foam
mannequin of himself home in the hope
that one day he'll be able to sneak a
suit off the set and have somewhere to
put it that isn't buried in a backpack
or hanging lifeless from a wall maybe he
finally had his chance during no way
home holland is pretty terrible at
keeping secrets who told you that
i don't know
so we're sure he'll spill the beans at
some point do you think he managed at
this go round there must have been a ton
of spidey suits hanging around triple
the amount as usual since we're entering
the spider-verse number 10 turns out
stan the man is a slippery guy here's a
pretty fun one winter soldier actor
sebastian stan has a huge supply of ky
jelly that he took from set he had three
people lubing up his arm so that he
could slide into his prosthetic so while
other actors were stealing costumes and
props stan went straight for the lube
well i gotta get in there the reason he
needed it all is turns out he bulked up
too much for the roll which made the
prosthetic just a bit tight number
eleven at least one spider-man was a
successful thief while tom holland
wasn't successful at getting hold of his
spidey suit that was not the case with
andrew garfield he says that it's no big
though as there's like 25 of them or so
all in different stages of tattered
depending on what's going on in the
scene on a scale of perfect condition to
nearly completely destroyed which one do
you think he got hold of and did you
know all three spidey actors have a
whatsapp together maybe garfield is
giving holland tips on how to swipe a
suit number 12. jackman might just be
the sneakiest marvel hero of them all
hugh jackman also got a hold of a
costume or two or one from every movie
hey kids
shut up tom holland really needs to up
his game here but jackman was a good
sport about it pulling quite the robin
hood as he sold most of them off for
charity
exactly like that keyword most
number 13 this prop might be worth as
much as vibranium but the material it's
made of sure isn't chris evans had 46
shields over the course of his time as
captain america in the mcu and he was
gifted one of them as well as one of his
cowls we're not sure which one he got
though an og aluminum one fiberglass or
the ones made of rubber so actors
wouldn't break their fingers when they
punched it
number 14 tom again this is embarrassing
get yourself a suit man tom holland also
took some pretty random things from the
set as well a whole load of different
things he took a blue screen and used it
as a poker table
number 15 even pratt has a suit chris
pratt's thievery is very much along the
lines of a robin hood move as well
captivated yet he took his jacket and
some of the other clothing so that he
could visit children's hospitals in
character oh
it's for the kids
number 16. robert downey jr has a
30-foot prop on display rdj is no normal
dude he's kind of a go big or go home
guy and you can bet he went big he took
home a 30-foot letter a remember this i
said uh wait why is this in in england
send it back to la i'll put it in my
office they're like seriously i said
yeah yeah i'll wait
number 17 even the king managed to keep
a prop of his own the late chadwick
boseman got to keep the kimoyo beads he
wore as black panther i have the beats
the commodore beast
he thought about taking home the suit
but didn't want to go to the trouble
number 18 reynolds is pretty slick
ryan reynolds is also in the club of
marvel actors who snuck away with a
costume is anybody keeping track we've
got andrew garfield spider-man hawkeye
thor wolverine star-lord and deadpool do
you think they ever get together and do
some larping
the live action role plays yeah this
whole thing
number 19. gillen kept probably one of
the weirdest props
no one's ever come in here so i've never
gotten to show them all of my nerdy
memorabilia
karen gillan got to keep the metal arm
that she wore as nebula an odd trophy
given she was not a huge fan of the five
hour makeup process this is a lovely
experience first thing in the morning
what we want to know is how does she
display the thing number 20. kate
blanchett kept a prop that belonged to a
different hero altogether
only thor can wield the hammer and
everyone else apparently
hemsworth isn't the only one to have
mjolnir hanging around his home kate
blanchett also got her hands on one i
got the hammer number 21 a frog is an
honorable prize michael rooker who
played yondu got to bring home a couple
of props that were special to him he got
to bring home an orb and a glass frog
that his character admires and he also
got to keep that signature finn atop
yondu's head
i like to stick them all in a roll on my
control comps from suits to weapons to
glass frogs the stuff actors take away
from set is pretty awesome and we still
want to know how they were able to get
all those mjolnirs offset without being
caught got any theories leave them in
the comments thanks for watching
[Music]